[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's sunday morning and another great
day for football welcome to the squad
ride presented by draftkings live
in the bleacher report app and shout out
to people watching on youtube
i'm cabbie richards alongside our
betting insider kelly stewart and a man
who can step into your wr1 slot
on any given sunday greg ivory welcome
back welcome back to the program this is
the seat this is the show where you
pick our nfl squad ride it's week five
we're three and one on the season we're
betting on touchdowns
so let's get them before we get to the
show
our a big shout out to our squad ride
leader last week
see till 2 who picked alvin kamara
to score a touchdown now you promised
cto2 you promised
you would pierce your nose if kamara
scored a touchdown
so it's your move homie oh you need the
video
yes earlier in social media we asked you
who's a lot to score a touchdown in week
five
show them the graphic we got some studs
on here
these are some of our favorites
and every week brings a new adventure
for the squad
guys have a look
kathy i think you should have left that
in for thanksgiving this weekend
[Applause]
i got one thing to say tamara
drive it i'm on the clock and everything
but that never stops me from giving you
blocks
i'm leaning towards the under at 44 and
a half and best believe the dawn will
strike again
[Music]
guys we are going to be riding with
jerick mckinnon
he has been doing a great job taking
over raheem moster
score touchdown he'll be in the end zone
guaranteed to put the money on that
i'm going with baker mayfield i see him
picking up a bootleg to the corner
against them colts in week five
hey alvin kamara hoot up baby
baby
let's go filling the energy filling the
energy cavi since i'm feeling the energy
i'm gonna put some of that energy
into these comments and give away some
hoodies i got fly
eagles fly 71 he's asking kelly he's
asking you this question should he start
digs today uh he has fuller on this
bench as a good backup what do you think
kelly
yeah i think if if you're going between
fuller and digs you have to go digs you
gotta go
dicks just for that fly eagles fly i'm
giving you a hoodie cabbie i have
one more okay my guy tony
tony rich i'm not even going to try to
pronounce your last name the producers
know you they're going to send you a a a
text message
or a dm saying that we're going to send
you a hoodie but he says the texans are
winning today
the texans are winning today since they
they haven't got a win
and i'm feeling the vibes from the
comments i'm going to give you a hoodie
because i also think the texans are
winning today
so let's go cabbie back to you shout out
let's get this show on the road shout
out to deshawn watson hopefully he can
pull it together after
bill o'brien was kelly's favorite coach
was sent uh
sent to early retirement let's say uh
it's time for
the first of our three pitches stanley
gillis
you're leading off you're in the
batter's box what is your lock for weeks
week five talk to us
what's up vr betting i want all y'all to
ride with me this week we got
lamar jackson rushing tv ravens are 13
high point favorites against the bengals
that run defense
sucks i guarantee you he gets in the end
zone let's ride
let's i like this guy let's
ride let's ride but i don't know i don't
know if i want to ride i just got
excited because of the energy from the
video but i do not know if i want to
ride
simply because i've been hearing lamar
jackson
he hasn't been at practice this week
kelly i've been hearing reports that he
hasn't been practicing
um i do believe he's going to play but
with that being said
i don't know if they're going to stretch
him and have him running the ball today
i can see
jk dobbins mark ingram getting the
getting the carries in the backfield and
letting lamar sling that rock a little
bit throw it to hollywood
throw it to uh andrews a little bit uh i
don't know kelly what are you thinking
greg that's where this is tough because
any time you're in a goal line situation
you have to assume
that lamar jackson is live to score a
touchdown that's the only scary part
here
look i agree with this as far as like
the game goes look i know
the bengals getting a lot of love i know
everybody thinks joe burrows going to
win the mvp shout out to justin
herbert all jokes aside i'm not touching
this game but i do think lamar jackson
scores a touchdown you know earlier in
the week g-money uh
lamar jackson was nursing a knee injury
and that's why he missed a couple of
days of practice just to your point
there
um what are the comments are saying are
they do they like this lamar jackson
rushing touchdown pick or they
are they riding with you guys saying
this kind of stay away from this one
kelly i mean cabbie i'm sorry kelly and
cabby the comments are all over the
place
to be honest i got big dog here he's
giving
kelly some props he said he'll bet on
kelly any day so uh
i mean we'll i'll ride with kelly any
day shout out to you big dog
you're walking away with a hoodie um i'm
not seeing
too much lamar will score but i do see
elijah corey he says lamar will score
shout out to you you're walking away
with hoodie my guy mikey
locks is in the comments make sure you
guys
fire all of mikey locks comments lamar's
a lot to score a rushing td
mikey locks is a rocket with lamar i got
one more for you cabbie
uh my guy s-s-e-b-e-e-r-n
i'm not gonna pronounce that i'm just
gonna spell it out for our producers
golden tate plus 175 to score a
touchdown
is a 100 percent lock i like when people
throw their nuggets in there cubby
cabbie i like when they throw their
nuggets in there and give us some other
locks
all right not seeing too many lamars but
uh we got golden tate
and uh we're rocking with that guy the
giants have some work to do another
under on
another winless team uh so far in the
nfl so hopefully uh
uh jones king daniel jones can get it
right um
danny dimes oh kelly you were saying
about
team should we should we should we be
aware or afraid of teams
that are double-digit favorites in 2020
you're right kathy we were talking about
this in our pre-production meeting and
why
i didn't like the bangles today we all
know i love looking for those underdogs
but double digit underdogs have
not fared well in the new nfl and what i
mean by the new nfl is basically the
last four years when they moved back
the p.a.t so it's a little concerning to
me here
uh to take the bangles on the flip side
i'm not touching the ravens
playing double digits in a divisional
game i just can't do it
i do think lamar is going to score a
touchdown here though okay so speaking
of lamar jackson listen it's uh
sunday morning trivia is good for the
soul and especially for soul
craves hoodies and our first trivia
question is about lamar jackson
and somebody's going to win a hoodie
because
unless greg gives them all away before
the end of the show but the question is
what meal does lamar jackson eat
before the game is it shrimp alfredo
pasta
or is it two chili dogs and an orange
juice
give me shrimp alfredo pasta or two
chili dogs in the comments
somebody's going to get a hoodie we're
going to give that away in a little bit
it's quite easy i have a ton of
questions regarding that mega we talking
about what about
early games breakfast are we talking
about like prime time games like
before monday night football i'm really
confused that is we're going to try to
get some clarity on that for you kels
that's that's a great question as far as
when he's going to carb load like that
okay let's get back to our pitches the
homie alan ramirez 6
believes that he's got the guy he's got
the lock in week five
drop your comments uh in the comments
section alan ramirez who you got
in order to be the best you gotta pick
the best and this week
kyler murray two rushing touchdowns at
least
one throwing touchdown at least and one
cute smile guaranteed calamari
guaranteed wow
whoa yes whoa whoa whoa that's a
technical rifle what do you mean it was
the perfect
punctuation no flags on the plate the
chef's kiss was
no exception it was way too many it was
way too many guaranteed
statistics being thrown in that pitch
i mean usually when these guys send me
those dm's and they tell me that they
have a guaranteed
absolute hammer lock i usually fade
is isn't that what we do kelly don't we
usually fade the guys that tell us that
they're in pictures just like
when charles barkley has his guarantee
it always makes me nervous we're on the
same side but you're right
those guarantees are always fun to fade
with that being said with that being
said
i don't know if i love kyler murray to
get in the end zone
i'm not loving the value here kelly plus
160
uh i just don't know what do you what is
your take what are you thinking kelly
i think you're right greg at plus 160
it's just like begging you to take
the yes this is tough i'm gonna say this
and i know i'm gonna get a lot of hate
for it i'm not saying
back the jets i'm just saying be
very very very cautious if you're gonna
lay the seven
with the cardinals on the road i gave
out the panthers last week
this cardinals team still has some
growing pains to get through
again i know it's the jets i know it
looks so easy
the whole world is going to have the
arizona cardinals in their teaser but
please be very cautious here with this
one
so how do you feel and how do you feel
about uh kyler murray
you you are you coming on the fence i
like kyler murray
i i really do i think he's gonna have a
prosperous nfl career but asking him to
score
on the road here in a very interesting
situation now
he's went to carolina back home now back
to the east coast those kind of travel
situations are not
always friendly to players especially
in the 2020 nfl season so just be a
little cautious on this game that's all
i'm asking for
that being said when the cardinals win
34-7 you guys can all
tweet me and tell me i told you so i'm
sure they will
either way the the audience likes to let
you know let you know cows
uh g-money are are people riding with
this kyler murray pick or are they
fading the kyler murray pick
i see a lot of fades aj croix
he's not rushing for two bruh yes
bruh i agree with you he's not rushing
for two touchdowns
you're walking away with a hoodie i
actually got some uh
some kyler love here my guy chris
some miese is saying let's ride kyler
murray today
uh you know what i'll throw you a hoodie
just for the love of
rocking with kylo murray you're walking
away with hoodie i got one more
cabbie michael ringer he said he's been
commenting every week
and still have no love for a hoodie he's
in green bay
with the frozen tundra guess what my guy
call me greg across because i'm sending
a hoodie
your way in green bay we're going to get
you warm brother
back to you cavs it it is hoodie season
and
and you can wear that proudly in
wisconsin
uh as soon as we get one to you so nice
work mike ringer kathy i want to give up
i want to give out a hoodie
zach is thinking exactly what i'm
thinking both of these meals will mess
up your stomach before the game
i was thinking the same thing that's why
i had all these questions
dev holmes uh somebody's gonna dm you it
ain't gonna be me so i'll give you a
hoodie
well listen when you're 22 or 23 years
old like lamar jackson is you can
basically eat anything
and then go burn 3000 calories uh during
the game but we're going to get to the
answer of that trivia question in just a
moment
uh kyle murray averaging eight yards a
rush and he's got four rushing
touchdowns
this season so we'll see if he gets to
five against the jets later today so two
pitches are in
stanley gillis has lamar jackson scoring
a rushing touchdown against cincinnati
and then alan ramirez as you just heard
has kyler murray
scoring a touchdown against the jets
before we get to our third pitch let's
get to this trivia quite the answer this
trivia question
earlier i asked you what meal does lamar
jackson eat before every game
greg picked two of you guys from the
comments somebody chose shrimp alfredo
pasta
and then someone else chose two chili
dogs and an oj
before the grave before the game gmoney
who you got
cabbie my guy matthew
boyle is rocking with the alfredo and we
got
rick thompson rocking with
the chili dog okay well the correct
answer is and shout out to producer max
for doing a deep dive to find this out
about lamar jackson
it is shrimp alfredo pasta is his
pre-game meal so remember friends
carbs they're good for you and it's all
right to carb load before a game
according to lamar jackson so you're
getting a hoodie matthew doyle matthew
doyler matthew boyle
boyle i got boyle with the beat kevin
okay matthew boyle congratulations
we're gonna send you a hoodie very soon
but it's still hoodie season it's
october
we gotta get you make sure your guys fit
is always fresh
so here you go kyla murray's teammate
deandre hopkins another food question
and another deep dive
does he put ketchup on the top of his
french fries
or does he put ketchup on the side and
then dip his french fries into the
ketchup these are
this is award-winning winning journalism
here on squad ride
so answer in the comments top of the
front gabby there's only one
correct answer here or dip wait which
one which one do you do you put
ketchup on the top of the fries or do
you dip the french fries into the
ketchup you
go up there and you steal a lid for the
drinks and you fill your lid
up with ketchup and you put it on the
side
that's ketchup on top of the lid of the
drink
no you like okay so they have the drinks
they have the straws all your stuff over
here to the side
then the ketchup container you take one
instead of those stupid little
like little white cups they give you no
ketchup you go get a big
lid for one of the big drinks and you
fill it up you just keep pumping up the
ketchup wait a second
i know drop it in the comments hold on
tell me i'm not crazy somebody tell me
i'm not crazy
yeah yeah we gotta get the taste wait
you put
okay you uh anyway so you're putting
ketchup on the that is that is it
yo shout out to uh kansas uh uh missouri
manhattan kansas cause you guys do
different things a little bit
differently there but
answer in the comments let us know how
you how you eat your your
your your fries with the ketchup okay so
that's deandre hopkins we're gonna get
to that answer
uh in just a second let's get to our
third and final pitch
aiding geyser it's your time to shine
talk to the squad who you got to score
touchdown a week what's up greg it's
aiden
um week five oh my god girlies
definitely fine in the end zone zeroed
out in my mind
i'm going home with that i'm getting
that sweatshirt zero doubt
it's a lock my guy
aiden what up brother shout out to you
actually i'm happy one i'm happy because
my guy aiden just
i mean he showed me love so guess what
i'm gonna reciprocate
and show you love we're gonna send you a
hoodie hated but also
i'm happy because he finally chose a
running back like this is a guy who's
getting paid
to actually run the ball so with that
being said
i love this pick i absolutely love this
pick i see this be a hot i see this
being a high scoring game
between the falcons and the panthers and
if the ball is inside the five you know
what they're gonna do they're gonna give
the ball to todd gurley he has four
touchdowns
in four weeks if it ain't broke cabbie
don't
fix it feed that man inside the five
let's go i'm rocking with this
draftking send me the odds boost right
now i'm ready i'm ready
you're ready i'm ready to look like that
and right all right i'm giving out one
more hoodie i don't care what the
producer says right now at
em and alas says this is his first time
watching the show
so he's going to get a hoodie thank you
for joining us yay
i'm excited new new viewers uh look todd
gurley
man todd gurley was so great for the
rams
then he gets traded well i know he got
hurt but he gets traded
he goes to the falcons what is going on
with this falcons team you
do not utilize my man like you need to
feed him the ball get him in the end
zone minus 155
is absolutely scary here that is a lot
of chalk for an
underutilized top five running back in
the league this makes no sense to me
look this game looks trappy i don't want
any part of it
i want the panthers to lose by less than
a touchdown i have them in a teaser
but the way this line is moved seems a
little off to me i don't know how
anybody can back this falcons team with
that defense especially land points i
know that they're at home
all things aside do i think todd
gurley's gonna score a touchdown
maybe i mean i would love julio jones to
score a touchdown
too but i don't know what's going on
with this atlanta falcons play calling
it just doesn't make a ton of sense to
me i'm gonna go with maybe
but no i don't love this to your point
kelly todd gurley is only
has only played 54 of atlanta's snap so
you're right they do need to get him the
ball a little bit more
greg what are the how are the commenters
reacting are they are they riding with
the top girly pick
are they fading the dog thomas aydah
comments is
vibing with your guy cabbie the comments
is vibing with your guy
exactly g-money let's ride my guy chris
a mino said that uh martin 1818 lock
that in greg said do score every game
guess what martin 18 18 you're walking
away with a hoodie because the guy
basically does average a score every
game uh
girly's going to score my guy jas
smitten he's rocking with todd gurley to
score
um they're rocking with gurley this is
the last one
rose ray gurley will not score
but score at least two tds so i'm
guessing he says girly's not going to
score a rushing touchdown but he's going
to he's going to score two
throwing receiving just because of your
your your comment and the vibes that
you're sending rosie ray i'm not going
to give you
brother that's not what we were talking
about
anyway cabbie let me end this let me end
this on the good note let me end this on
the good note my guide not
darius garland winner from last week he
said top gurley is a lock
yes todd gurley is a lock but darius i
gave you a hoodie last week therefore
i'm not giving you one today
unfortunately wait cabbie we have to end
this on the good note
we have to end this on the right liam
o'connell
liam o'connell 23 let me get a hoodie
please yo
well guess what liam this is the season
of giving
you guys call me gregor claus i'm
letting you
walk away today's show with the hoodie
we're gonna send you one
cabbie back to you brother got you got
you
guys uh great pick so so you guys have
heard the three pitches let's do a quick
recap here
we got lamar jackson to score a touch a
rushing touchdown against cincinnati
kyler murray to score a touchdown
against the jets
rushing as well and todd gurley a
rushing touchdown or receiving touchdown
against the panthers that's the that's
the board
greg who had your favorite pitch
cabbie come on man is this really even
the question you know who had my
favorite fish my guy
aiden my guy aiden the one who who chose
todd gurley who's actually a running
back like i said he's
actually the one that's on this the one
that we're deciding from that's actually
getting paid
to run the ball so with that being said
i see my guy todd gurley inside the five
in this high scoring game against
atlanta
carolina getting the ball inside the
five
and putting it in the end zone lock it
in right now let's go ty
and uh shout out to aiden the lock of
the week for the best
uh haircut of the week the best lettuce
of the week kelly who had your favorite
pitch
i need to get that dude to comb all
jokes aside i think
look i think all three of these guys
could easily score a touchdown this week
but i like lamar jackson the best i know
the greg mentioned uh some of lamar's
injuries but
again any point in time you're within
two or three yards of the end zone you
know
you have a good shot of lamar carrying
the rock himself taking it to the house
especially against this bengals
defensive line i just see
lamar being the easiest one here so
that's what i got to go with okay nice
all right so audience squad you have all
the information you need
now it's on you to decide our week five
squad ride we're three and one this year
and we want good vibes only and enough
to win
to buy a playstation five in a couple of
weeks so do you like
todd todd gurley do you like lamar
jackson do you like kyla murray
drop your picks in the comments and the
uh and draftkings is boosting the odds
on whatever you decide
this week so while the votes are being
tallied by our producers
let's answer that final trivia question
that i asked you earlier
about kylo murray's teammate deandre
hopkins
does he put his ketchup on the top of
his french fries
or on the side and dip the french fries
into the ketchup g-money picked two
people from the comments
i'm sure that the the comment section is
on fire because people are either on
one side of the other g-money who do we
have
who are we potentially giving a hoodie
to
cabs we're potentially giving a hoodie
to
my guy liam o'connell i gotta show you
some love okay
i just gave you the hoodie he was one of
the guys that said top he's on top with
liam
liam said on top and then dip is my guy
duh almighty aj okay
the almighty aj and liam o'connell
are the two people that we're going to
decide from well our producers did
another
deep deep dive in it and according to
twitter
deandre hopkins dips his fries into
ketchup so the mighty aj
is the winner congratulations you are
getting a hoodie liam
because of greg's generosity he just
gave you a hoodie so it wasn't fair to
get you one anyway but
the mighty aj you had the correct answer
so we're sending you a hoodie
asap uh appreciate you guys watching
and we have more hoodies to give away
next week same time same bad channel
so ride with us all right so it's time
for the big reveal
who are we riding with in week five the
votes
are in and the winning bet is
lamar jackson to score a touchdown
against cincinnati
that's who we're riding with we are all
sprinkling on this bet
because we are riding as a family here
on squad ride
the odds go from minus 106 to plus 300
thank you
to our friends at draftkings for
boosting these odds there's the fire
emoji we're gonna see some fire for sure
in that ravens versus
bengals game check br betting social for
a link to the boot the odds boost
and we want screenshots of your bets we
want winners
as always we like to feature them we
like to receive them so don't forget to
send us
your there are three games in prime time
this week little sprinkle here
sprinkle there sprinkle and everywhere
but if you want a best bet
you're in the right place kelly stewart
talk to the people give them your best
bet
cabbie gabby cabbie cabbie look we all
know my best bets
have not been the best not since the
week
one with the new orleans saints over the
tampa bay buccaneers
but i really like this week's bet and i
bet you guys do too
because i saw a ton of you guys dropping
it in the comment section
so much so that this one moved from
seven to seven and a half in some spots
so please
shop around get the best of the number
there's a big
monetary difference between seven and
seven and a half here
all things aside i like the pittsburgh
steelers
in a couple of reasons why you have this
eagles team
sorry greg i know they finally got a w
against your niners last week but that
was a nick mullins lead niners that is a
banged up niners team and the eagles
really didn't do much other than
capitalize
off a few bad plays to win that game now
they went from the west coast
back to the east coast that kind of
travel schedule
is not always conducive for certain
teams especially teams
with injuries like the eagles on the
flip side you have the steelers who got
well an unplanned bye week because their
game
got cancelled so they've got to nurse
those injuries big ben
juju smith schuster i expect a big game
for both those guys so make sure you
have them
in your fantasy spots over a couple of
other players that being said i'm all
over the steelers minus seven it is my
best bet
for nfl week five excellent work goal
excellent work get on draftkings fire up
the app get that wager in
if you want to rock with our mvp kelly
stewart thank you again for that
so congratulations to all our winners
shout out to all the commenters we
appreciate that and
thank you to this wait wait wait wait
cabbie yeah gabby before we get out of
here
you know what i gotta do you know what i
gotta do
sloane 58 we need to get some of those
hoodies
into chief's kingdom i know it gets cold
in kansas city ain't that right kelly
it gets cold in kansas city yeah
especially at arrowhead when you're
sitting in those nosebleed seats
don't be in the nose please but anyway
anyway
i'm gonna have you walk away with a
hoodie sloan58 i'm not
done cabbie luke trinter11 grega claus
hoodie please brother
you called my name so i am coming greg
across is my name you're walking away
with a hoodie luke
uh orange hat boy says dippity dip
dip i guess he's referring to uh is that
deandre hopkins dip in the frog yeah
yeah
but guess what i i like the dippity dip
dip that sounds like a little dippity
dip dip but guess what dippity dip dip
i'm going to give you a
a hoodie we're going to send you a
hoodie orange hat boy cabbie i have
one more cabbie one more my guy cozy
bryant best of luck today
to all the br bet pals he's sending
positive vibes he's sending positive
energy
and so guess what i'm going to be
positive and send you a hoodie brother
love that yes appreciate the good vibes
because we don't we have good vibes only
here on the squad ride
thank you to the to the the riders who
pitched
uh shout out to aiden with the with the
loaf stanley gillis and alex ramirez
much appreciated
send us your takes for a chance to be
featured on squad ride next week
alongside kelly stewart and greg ivory
my name is cabbie richards good luck
today
thanks for watching and peace
[Music]
you